the show Cops yeah I actually had cops
ride with me you did I did have cops
right with me you'd be interested in how
that goes the way cops operates is is
that there's there's there's a few film
Crews there's a sound guy and there's a
camera guy
and I think I I don't remember how many
men buy it was very few like four or
five of these teams and these guys were
so interesting um they essentially go
out and by the time they came to our
Police Department it had really changed
uh because of civil law where you
weren't able just to film [ __ ] and throw
it on TV you had to get waivers from
everyone that was involved and that
involved criminals signing off saying
yeah you can use that [ __ ] which is
[ __ ] so stupid if you signed off on
that [ __ ] you're the dumbest guy on the
face of the Earth because it's all now
evidence it could be used against you in
court so it was really tough to get
those guys to sign off but believe it or
not you know unfortunately when it comes
to Crime you're not dealing with a lot
of Scholars so you would get a lot of
signatures but by then it was a little
tougher so what they would do is is they
would ride with you they would pick an
officer and they they I I'm fortunate
enough to be picked and they would ride
with you for two months every single
shift
yeah and that time I was working three
twelves which is three shifts twelve
three twelve hour shifts Friday Saturday
Sunday which was the busiest that's why
at graveyard so that's why they wanted
to ride with me
so you would go out with these guys and
it and the man it was like it was like
it was like performance anxiety you know
what I mean it's like oh yeah I felt
this 20s yeah right Jesus I just felt
this need to perform man you know and
and it's harrowing police work is some
days there's just nothing going on you
know you gotta you gotta self-generate
whether it be tickets and hope you can
come up with stuff so I always felt this
pressure to go out but speaking with
these guys and their experiences like
the the sound guy had been shot yeah in
the leg
um uh the other guy something that
happened their stories were awesome
because they had been all over they were
telling me stories dude I was going like
[ __ ] that is so awesome dude I can't
even believe you experienced all this
[ __ ] that you've experienced I mean
these guys probably walked away from
that show and have mental problems
themselves yeah because they they've
essentially were cops all the time on
patrol well imagine you're a sound guy
and you're like oh it sounds like
somebody got shot and then it's [ __ ]
you
whatever you know I mean they had all
kinds these guys had great stories so
essentially they would ride with you the
whole time and the issue became is you
felt so much pressure to get material oh
yeah um that when they rode with me they
rode with two different officers me and
another guy and I literally didn't make
the show
I literally didn't make the show I
didn't well and the one time I did the
guy wouldn't sign off and they couldn't
make the cuts to make it relevant so I
they I literally didn't make but I
actually became really good friends with
these guys because we'd spent so much
time talking that I I was talking to I
don't now but I was talking to him for
quite a bit calling where you at and
what's going on and wow but the way that
they do cops is when when you watch it
it looks like it's it's it's Progressive
it looks like this is happening you know
what I mean and it never registers with
you and like they go they're in the car
and they get the radio call and it's
like ah you know
372 respond to non-breather yeah
whatever it is and you see the cop okay
and then all of a sudden he's driving
and then it cuts away and you see the
car making a right hand turned onto a
street and never really registers you
would go well how the [ __ ] did they know
he was going there to be on that thing
you know what I mean I'm a guy that has
no idea of the industry and editing all
that so it wasn't until they rode with
me and I watched the cops and I went
well how the [ __ ]
are they gaining all these angles and
[ __ ] so what ends up happening is find
out is they would we would have the
situation they would get out and they
would they would be in it I mean you
would have to literally tell these guys
look at dude you need to step the [ __ ]
back you know you need to get behind
that car right now I get it but I I need
you to do that so they were always up on
you and they'd be filming and getting
everything they can and then they would
go back and go hey look I think this is
something we can use so this is what I
need you to do I need you to drop my
camera guy off on that corner and I want
you to go back to this
Street and then I want you to fake like
you're responding to the radio I'm going
to be in it filming you you know with
the other camera
so there's acting involved you know what
I mean and I was a young kid and I just
couldn't do it dude I'm just not an
actor you know what I mean so they would
like be filming so all those guys you
see doing it that's all acting up until
the actual scenario wow but you never
really never really crossed my mind no
yeah in my mind I'm just saying oh that
makes sense they have footage everywhere
and they're just getting all the you
know that's like they're just dialed in
and getting everything that's
okay now I want you to come and open
that door you know what I mean and then
you go back and watch an episode and go
okay now this [ __ ] makes sense why
didn't that ever register with me this
is all [ __ ] you know I mean except
for the actual scenarios themselves yeah
you know they would just film it raw and
they would do their editing magic and
and make an episode but it takes it
takes two months every single night with
two different teams for a half hour
episode
and they said they struggle sometimes to
get that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one